The visually stunning and heartfelt Soul is
one of Pixar's most acclaimed films to date
and hidden in the movie are stacks of deep-cut
references to other classics such as
Inside Out, Toy Story, and Wall-E.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and in this
video I'm revealing every easter egg and crucial
detail you might have missed in Pixar's Soul.
There are some spoilers, so take care.
The best place to begin our Soul easter
egg hunt is in the Hall of Everything,
one of the locations in the Great Before
where new souls go to find their spark.
In the sky you can see Charles Muntz's blimp,
the Spirit of Adventure, from Pixar's Up.
Floating in the distance, and a little more
difficult to see, is the Axiom from Wall-E,
one of the giant Starliner spacecrafts built by
Buy n Large during the evacuation of Earth.
And the monorail is a nod to Metroville
and the second Incredibles movie where
the city's monorail track was destroyed
during the battle with the Underminer.
Back on the ground, the Aztec temple is a
reference to Coco's Land of the Dead and
the Aztec stone structures that form the base
of the buildings in that movie's afterlife.
And another Coco easter egg crops up
later on when Twenty Two is deliberately
messing with humans in the Zone.
After she interrupts the tattoo artist,
you can spot a very Coco-style
skull in a portrait on the wall.
The Pizza Planet truck with its distinctive red
and white rocket on the roof is here in the hall.
The truck originally appeared
in Pixar's very first feature
film Toy Story and has shown up in
almost every Pixar film so far.
And resting on the side of the truck is
a double bass, an instrument that's also
prominently on display in Joe's apartment.
The garbage truck behind the Pizza Planet
truck is likely a Toy Story 3 reference
to the truck that Sid worked on as a
garbage collector and the one that Lotso
ended up on at the end of that movie.
You'll find the A113 easter egg on a set
of street signs in the Hall of Everything.
The appearance of A113 in Pixar's films is
a tribute to the classroom at California
Institute of the Arts where many of
the studio's animators studied.
The suspended whale is a nod to Finding
Dory and the giant mammal on display in the
indoor exhibit at the Marine Life Institute.
And this orange-coloured dinghy, complete with
on-board motor and two souls sitting inside,
tips its hat to another scene from that movie
where two workers from the institute
pick Dory out of the ocean after they
discover she's caught in a piece of plastic.
And further back is the Pixar lamp, aka Luxo Jr,
who made his first Pixar appearance
in a short film of the same name.
The lamp also appears on the
production logo of every Pixar film.
Next to the lamp is a black piano,
an allusion to the piano Joe plays
at the Half Note club in New York.
Speaking of the club, there was an
easter egg to one of its stars in
Onward via a record by the Dorothea
Williams Quartet in Ian and Barley's house.
Because Soul's director Pete Docter also directed
Inside Out, there are many shout-outs
to that beloved movie in the hall.
The tower with a pennant on top just behind the
temple appears to be from the Princess Dreamworld
castle in Inside Out's Imagination Land, which was
demolished after Riley's memories of it faded.
And the truck is a likely reference to
the same trucks from Inside Out that
the Mind Workers used to plough old
faded, memories into the Memory Dump.
This purpley-blue trampoline is
similar to one which appeared in
Riley's early childhood memories.
There's also the Golden Gate Bridge
which Riley saw for the first time
when she moved to San Francisco.
And while trolleys aren't unique to San Francisco,
Riley did marvel at one when it drove past her
family's car as she arrived in the city.
The studio chair could also be a reference
to the one Rainbow Unicorn sat
in at Dream Productions.
An interesting Brave easter egg pops up in
the video played during the mentor training
presentation by one of the Jerrys.
We see a soul find its spark after
it successfully fires an arrow into
the centre of one of three targets,
alluding to the scene where Merida
demonstrates her archery skills
during the presentation of suitors, by
firing her arrow into three targets.
This large, curiously-shaped object resembles
the top-heavy rock called Willy's Butte that
Doc Hudson challenged Lightning McQueen
to a race around in the first Cars movie.
And the cactus plants down on the ground might
also be a call-back to how, during that race,
Lightning ended up skidding out of control
and falling into a cactus patch.
The passenger plane is likely a nod to
Everett, the jumbo jet that Mater narrowly
avoided crashing into in the Cars sequel.
And London's iconic Big Ben could be a
reference to Big Bentley, where
Mater was briefly imprisoned.
The Eiffel Tower from Paris which also appeared
in Cars 2 is here as well, although this
could also be a reference to Ratatouille.
And this biplane here may be one of the light
aircraft flown by Charles Muntz's dogs in Up.
And it might also be a hat-tip to Barney Stormin,
the Piston Cup skywriting-plane
from the first Cars movie.
The chessboard that a couple of souls
are playing is likely a shout-out to
the Pixar short film Geri's Game, in which
an elderly man plays chess with himself.
This giant Ferris Wheel is probably a reference
to the fairground attraction from Toy Story 4.
The canoe is likely a shout-out to
Pixar's 2020 short film Loop.
And this large dog looks like it could
be either Dug or Beta from Up.
After Joe and Twenty Two leave the Hall of
Everything, they go inside "Just A Box" where
the iconic Pixar ball makes its appearance.
The Luxo ball is a regular Pixar easter egg
and a homage to the short film, Luxo Jr.
The pink flamingo in this room could also
be a nod to the flamingo character "Sunny
Florida" from Pixar's short film Knick Knack.
Also in this room is Twenty Two's collection
of her previous mentors' name stickers.
There are a huge number of deceased,
real-life historical figures who in
the Pixar universe once tried to help
the obstinate soul find its spark.
"Copernicus..."
"The world doesn't revolve around you, 22!"
"Muhammad Ali..."
"You are the greatest pain in the butt!"
"Stop talking!
My unconscious mind hates you!"
Some interesting names you'll find here that
weren't mentioned in the movie include Joan
of Arc, Confucius, Albert Einstein,
iconic soul singer Aretha Franklin,
and comic book legend Jack Kirby.
There's also Joe Ranft,
one of Pixar's original animators who
worked on all of the studio's movies,
as well as voicing various characters, before he
tragically passed away in a car accident in 2005.
There have been many tributes to him in Pixar
movies over the years, including naming one
of the scarers in Monsters Inc after him.
There are some nice extra details in the scene
where we discover that Marie Antoinette
was one of Twenty Two's former mentors.
Notice that Twenty Two is holding up a
piece of cake, a reference to the phrase
"Let Them Eat Cake" that's been famously
misattributed to the last queen of France.
Also notice how Marie Antoinette is
just a floating head without a body,
referring to the fact that she was
beheaded during the French Revolution.
"Nobody can help you!
Nobody!"
And the way she emphasises
and repeats the word "no-body"
in this moment is a clever bit of word play.
The scene also reminds me of the funny moment
in Toy Story where Buzz bemoans being
made to have tea with two beheaded dolls.
"One minute you're defending the whole galaxy.
And suddenly you find yourself suckin' down
Darjeeling with Marie Antoinette
and her little sister."
Something particularly hard to find this time
around was the cameo by John Ratzenberger,
who's always voiced at least one
character in every Pixar film.
He's not credited in the movie, but listen very
carefully as Joe walks through the Hall of You.
There are various on-screen characters who
tell him "Sorry Joe" as they turn him down,
and then off-screen in the background you'll
hear Ratzenberger's distinctive voice say
"We're looking for something different."
There's also a fun detail in the scene where
Twenty Two tries to find her spark
by experimenting with chemicals.
The chemical formula for the
compound behind her is theobromine,
one of the principal stimulants in chocolate.
And notice how the chemical reaction gives
off a little cloud of brown powder.
It might also be a little shout-out to
Russell and Kevin from Up who were both chocolate
fans, especially as that movie was directed
by Pete Docter, the director of Soul.
Another Pixar movie that Docter directed
was Monsters Inc and there's a moment in the
You Seminar that links back to that film.
After souls are paired up with their mentor, Jerry
conjures up a door and sends them through it,
instantly transporting them to another location.
This portal-like quality of doors in the Great
Before is similar to how they work at the
Monsters Inc factory where monsters can
cross over into the Human World through doors.
And this detail is crucial for how Soul fits
into the Pixar Theory.
More on that later.
Although many of the personality pavilions in the
Great Before were designed to be abstract-looking,
a few of them were deliberately given
specific shapes by Pixar's animators.
So, the Aloof Pavilion is shaped
like a nose pointed up in the air,
and there's also a little icon of a person with
their nose pointed up just above the entrance.
There's a clue to spiritual sign
twirler Moonwind's ability to project
his consciousness into the Astral Plane via
the words on his T-shirt "Living the Dream".
The CND peace symbol pin that he
wears on his jacket is also the
design of the anchor for the ship that he
navigates whenever he gets in the Zone.
And a much older peace symbol, a
giant dove with an olive branch,
forms the figurehead of that ship.
The name of the group that Moonwind commands,
Mystics Without Borders, is a play on the name of
real-life organisation Médecins Sans Frontières,
aka Doctors Without Borders.
Much of Soul also takes place
in New York and there are many Pixar
easter eggs hidden around the city.
For instance, on the subway there's
an ad for a company called "Brang"
with the slogan "What did you brang?"
This is an ingenious easter egg to Riley's father
from Inside Out, as Brang is the name of the tech
start-up company he joined in San Francisco.
There's an easter egg to Luca, Pixar's
next film after Soul, in the window
of a travel agency that Joe walks past.
The poster is a painting of an Italian seaside
town with the words "Visit Portorosso".
Luca is a coming-of-age story set
on the Italian Riviera.
When Joe discovers he's in a
New York hospital, there's a subtle clue that
Twenty Two will end up in his body if you look
at the monitoring machine by Joe's bedside
because the model is a "Smrt-vu PX-22".
And it's no coincidence that Twenty Two was
chosen for the name of the soul that Joe mentors,
because there have been a total of 22 Pixar
feature films prior to the release of Soul.
There's a lovely moment in the movie when
Joe, via Twenty Two who's in his body,
has a heartfelt conversation with his mother.
On the wall in the room where this happens
is a little picture with the
motto "Sewing Mends The Soul".
It might be a common saying, but it also has
a double meaning in this moment because this
conversation with Joe's mother is crucial for
Twenty Two finally coming around to understand
the pleasures of living and life on Earth.
And so, this scene literally mends the
soul we know as Twenty Two.
There's a funny moment when Joe
as Mr Mittens goes to fetch a slice of pizza
for Twenty Two and, as he returns, he sees a
rat dragging a piece of pizza along the floor,
an amusing reference to the Pizza Rat meme.
Also here is an interesting
bit of graffiti which looks
like it might be a second A-1-1-3 easter egg.
I can't say for sure as the potential A is more
of a triangle here, but the A-1-1-3 easter egg
did appear as a graffiti in Inside Out which, as
I mentioned earlier, was by the same director.
There's an interesting potential connection
between Soul and Toy Story 4 that you
can see via the name of the removal
company "Move It" whose truck is on the
road where Joe falls down the manhole.
It seems plausible that the "Move It" removals
business could be connected to the "Ship It"
delivery company which had a truck parked outside
the antiques store in the fourth Toy Story movie.
"Ship It" first appeared in the Toy
Story of Terror short where a courier
working for the company was picking up
packages from the Sleep Well Motel.
And there's a deep-cut Disney easter egg in
this scene via the name "Retlaw" on this van.
This is a reference to "Retlaw Enterprises",
originally known as "Walt Disney Miniature
Railroad", a company set up by Walt Disney
himself in 1950 to manage the rights to
his name and a couple of attractions
at Disneyland that belonged to him.
"Retlaw" is the name "Walter"
spelled backwards.
A regular easter egg in many of Pixar's movies
is the Chinese food box which makes at least
two appearances in Soul.
You can see it on the
hedge fund manager's desk here.
The box has a very specific design and,
among other films, has appeared in Soul director
Pete Docter's Inside Out and Monsters Inc;
while its first appearance was in A Bug's
Life where it was called the "Chinese Cabinet
of Metamorphosis" by Manny.
"The Chinese Cabinet of Metamorphosis."
You can spot the same takeout box design later
on when Joe crashes into a garbage can and his
hand gets stuck in a discarded box.
The existence of recurring objects like
this box in so many Pixar films like
Soul is evidence for the Pixar Theory
that all of the animation studio's films
exist in a single connected universe.
And I've made a separate full video explaining
exactly how Soul proves that theory correct.
There's a card here, plus there's a link
to watch it in the video description.
By the way, I enjoyed how Mr Mittens
the therapy cat brought lots of physical
comedy to the New York part of the movie,
and the Art of Soul book reveals that the name
of the cat therapy service he works for is called
"Feline Better", a play on 'Feeling Better'.
The Art of Soul book also reveals the meaning
behind the symbols on Twenty Two's pass.
Twenty Two is apparently a "moody,
extroverted cynic who's extremely punctual".
I can thoroughly recommend checking out The Art
of Soul book to appreciate and learn much more
about many of Soul's early concepts and how they
progressed to their final version in the film.
I'll add a link to where you can get the
book in the video description below.
Now, if you didn't sit through the
credits for Soul, you might have
missed out on a little post-credits scene
in which Terry pops up for a final time:
"Hi!
Movie's over.
Go home!"
This is a joke
in the spirit of the post-credits scene in
Ferris Bueller's Day Off and also Deadpool
which itself riffed on the John Hughes film,
and it's clearly intended for the traditional
cinema experience, so it doesn't work quite
so well watching at home on Disney Plus,
though it is a fun little reward for
those who watch right to the end.
Now, what other easter eggs or
cool details did you spot in Soul?
And how do you rate it among
your favourite Pixar movies?
If you enjoyed this, then a
thumbs-up is hugely appreciated!
Next tap left to see how Soul proves the Pixar
Theory that Boo from Monsters Inc travelled
back in time to become the witch in Brave or tap
right for something else you're sure to like.
Thanks for watching and see you next time.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!